j'ouvre tout de suite le second débat de
ce sens public consacré à ce nouveau
pacte financier mondial objectif du
sommet nord-sud qui se tient depuis
aujourd'hui à Paris sommet pour relever
le double défi de la dette et du climat
objectif aussi pour Emmanuel Macron et
ses alliés européens et américain de
reprend la main face aux puissances
chinoises et russes Mathias
c'était un engagement pris au lendemain
de la COP 27 acharmel shake Emmanuel
Macron reprend alors à son compte
l'initiative de bridge Town une
proposition faite par la première
ministre de l'île de la Barbade à savoir
repenser le système financier mondial
face au défi du dérèglement climatique
ce qui nous est demandé aujourd'hui
c'est une transformation absolue et non
une réforme de nos institutions cette
transformation est nécessaire parce que
alors que le monde savait depuis les
années 1990 que nous étions confrontés
au réchauffement climatique nous avons
choisi de ne pas suivre les conseils des
scientifiques et ce qui aurait pu être
fait en plus d'un siècle doit maintenant
être fait en moins d'une décennie
à Paris le président français a convié
pendant deux jours plus de 200
participants dont une quarantaine de
chefs d'État étrangers principalement
venus des pays du Sud taxation des
transactions financières de l'aviation
ou encore du commerce maritime certains
pays d'Afrique d'Asie et d'Amérique
latine plaide pour une refondation
totale du système pris à la gorge par
leur dette souveraine beaucoup de chefs
d'État réclament une baisse des taux
d'intérêt sous peine de ne pas pouvoir
lutter surtout les fronts jamais aucun
décideur aucun pays ne doit avoir à
choisir entre la réduction de la
pauvreté et la protection de la planète
et j'ai entendu beaucoup de décideurs
ces derniers mois parfois ces dernières
années très souvent dire au fond vous
nous expliquez vous qui avez déjà réglé
le problème de la pauvreté ce qu'il
faudrait faire en matière de transition
climatique les choix qu'on devrait
prendre mais nous nous n'avons pas
encore réglé le problème de la pauvreté
récemment les Nations Unies se sont
engagées à lever 100 milliards de
dollars par an pour aider les pays du
Sud à réduire leurs émissions de carbone
selon plusieurs ONG il faudrait plus de
2000 milliards pour y arriver
de ce sommet avec mes invités
sylviematelli bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes économiste directrice adjointe de
l'Institut de relation internationale et
stratégique François bienvenue vous êtes
démographe professeur au Collège de
France et titulaire de la chair
migration et société auteur de ce livre
immigration le grand déni publié aux
éditions du Seuil j'accueille également
Guillaume Compain bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes chargés de campagne climat à Oxfam
France et Laetitia cruppa est resté à
mes côtés éditorialise politique je vous
propose de voir cette tribune qui a été
signée dans le monde plus de 60 pays
représentés à Paris plusieurs chefs
d'états gouvernement qui signent cette
tribune le titre c'est nous devons faire
des transitions justes et solidaires une
priorité
cosignée par Joe Biden Ursula vanderline
Emmanuel Macron lave Scholt ou encore le
prénom du Sénégal Macky Sall et la
première ministre de la Barbade Mia
motley Sylvie ma télé je commence avec
vous que peut-on attendre d'un test
est-ce que ça peut vraiment faire ém
erger un nouveau pacte financier mondial
on est dans une ambition qui semble un
peu démesurée
la question est compliquée parce qu'a
priori ça peut pas grand chose ce sommet
mais c'est important aussi de réunir
tout un ensemble de dirigeants pour
poser les problèmes pour alerter
peut-être les sociétés civiles et
essayer de de faire bouger les lignes je
crois que le précédent le précédent
qu'on peut citer sur ce type de sommet
c'est le One Planet semi au début des du
premier mandat d'Emmanuel Macron et ça a
été un moment je vais dire de prise de
conscience des acteurs financiers que la
facture liée au changement climatique
elle est très très coûteuse et qu'il
fallait commencer à bouger effectivement
du côté des acteurs privés ça a commencé
à bouger ça veut dire que la finance
mondiale c'est un peu redirigé vers des
pas totalement on a un très très loin
mais vers des investissements on va dire
plus vert plus éco-responsable et vous
aurez noté le cynisme de ce que je viens
vous dire c'est à dire on prend
conscience en sciences en ce moment là
que ne rien faire va coûter beaucoup
plus cher à terme donc c'est un
investissement dans l'avenir on se rend
compte à un moment donné que il faut
investir dans le changement climatique
parce que c'est c'est ce qui va
permettre de survivre dans la vie tout à
fait il y aura un retour sur
investissement il n'empêche qu'on a
continué à financer les énergies
fossiles et autres le le les acteurs
financiers sont toujours très intéressés
par le retour sur investissement et
investissent toujours comme ils le
doivent mais ça avait fait prendre
conscience de ça véritablement est-ce
que ça va être le cas là c'est plus
compliqué parce que les enjeux
financiers pour les acteurs privés sont
beaucoup plus discutables en fait
aujourd'hui vous avez une un changement
climatique dans les pays du Sud qui
vient percuter une situation de pauvreté
de pauvreté qui s'est amplifiée
j'imagine qu'on va en parler parce que
différentes crises et parce qu'une
mondialisation en crise et de fait pour
un acteur privé le retour sur
investissement il est compliqué dans un
investir dans un pays en guerre en se
disant je fais le bien c'est pas
forcément c'est pas forcément
l'analyse ça peut marcher oui mais ça
rapporte rien
que François ayant une dimension aussi
sociologique c'est-à-dire si on regarde
les les habitants de ces pays pauvres
ils peuvent à juste titre nous nous dire
bah écoutez vous avez profité des
ressources de nos ressources de
l'aviation carbonée j'en passe et des
meilleurs et aujourd'hui vous nous dites
faites des efforts que vous n'avez pas
fait oui j'étais récemment au Nigéria à
Lagos qui est une ville où vous avez des
inégalités absolument prodigieuses des
immeubles absolument magnifiques de
grands hôtels avec des générateurs d'une
taille absolument incroyable très
puissante qui font que dans toute la
ville on entend le bruit des générateurs
pour lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique
solaire évidemment parce qu'il y a
tellement de coupures d'électricité que
voilà et effectivement ils ont aussi des
problèmes climatiques avec la bordure du
Sahel la partie nord du pays communique
avec le Niger par exemple et là ils
étudient vraiment de près tout ça mais
bien sûr ils nous font le reproche
d'avoir largement
ignoré et négligé
le développement et la lutte contre les
climats et le reboisement etc votre avis
sur ce sur ce sommet je lisais c'est le
début d'un processus la définition des
principes de réforme à venir bon ça veut
dire que ça va on parler de l'urgence ça
va encore prendre des années c'est ce
qu'on appelle les pactes dans les
séminations unies ou compact en anglais
ça n'a pas de valeur juridique
contraignante ce sont c'est un
engagement symbolique très fort ça peut
avoir une grande force symbolique c'est
ce qui vient d'être dit mais ensuite
est-ce que c'est l'incitation économique
qui va fonctionner ça sera pas la
contrainte juridique que de toute façon
donc effectivement c'est ce n'est qu'un
départ mais certainement pas une
garantie pour que les choses changent
réellement Guillaume Compain il faut
quand même on l'a dit et on le on
l'imagine mais je vois bien que vous
nous détailler les effets de du
réchauffement climatique sur ces pays
les plus pauvres ce sont les pays est-ce
qu'on peut dire ce sont les pays les
plus pauvres et les plus impactés oui
complètement on peut dire que évident le
lien que vous avez été évident parmi les
pays les plus vulnérables au changement
climatique à la fois dans les impacts du
changement climatique et leur capacité
de réponse notamment budgétaire c'est
énormément de pays du Sud comme le Niger
qu'on a évoqué précédemment
l'Afghanistan les pays comme le Kenya
aussi qui souffre énormément de bas
d'une sécheresse par exemple dans la
dans la Corne de l'Afrique ça fait cinq
ans cinq années qu'il y a une sécheresse
historique n'a jamais été connue à ce
niveau là et qui est créatrice d'une
crise alimentaire
absolument effroyable on estime que en
ce moment en Éthiopie au Kenya au Soudan
du Sud et en Somalie il y a une personne
qui meurt à peu près toutes les 28
secondes
c'est pour réaliser aussi la réalité de
ce qui se passe et en fait l'enjeu de ce
nouveau pacte c'est-à-dire que quand des
grands dirigeants se réunissent à Paris
au Palais Brognard pour discuter d'un
nouveau pacte financier mondial ils sont
là normalement pour trouver des
solutions massives
urgentes rapidement pour permettre à des
personnes de survivre de s'adapter aux
changements climatiques et c'est une
question de dignité mais c'est aussi une
question de justice historique aussi on
pourra peut-être en parler bien sûr
est-ce que est-ce que par exemple
puisqu'on cherche des des décisions
rapides annulées la dette d'un pays
victime d'une catastrophe climatique
extrême ça a été évoqué
pour l'instant suspendre pardon j'ai dit
annuler vous voyez je suis trop
optimiste suspendre et justement je
pense c'est déjà une bonne chose
suspendre les paiements de la dette en
cas de catastrophe climatique qui qui
frappent un pays qui peut perdre parfois
quasiment l'intégralité de son PIB voire
plus je crois que c'est le cas de la
République Dominicaine suite à un
cyclone en suite à une catastrophe
naturel naturel et donc n'a plus aucune
ressource en fait pour pour bâtir sa
reconstruction et encore moins pour
s'adapter aux futurs événements
climatiques qui pourraient le frapper
donc dans ces cas-là oui des annulations
de dette au-delà même des suspensions de
paiement de dette nous semble essentiels
c'est déjà arrivé c'est déjà arrivé les
précédents chocs financiers
internationaux il y a une vingtaine
d'années il y a eu tout un processus
d'annulation conjointe de dettes c'est
quelque chose qui est tout à fait
faisable et qui est nécessaire si
l'humatellit est-ce que ça met en péril
le système financièrement mondial de
suspendre la dette des pays frappés par
une catastrophe climatique extrême qui
qui la détient majoritairement cette
dette en quelque sorte alors en fait
lors des annulations de dette dans les
années 90 on s'est aperçu que ça ne
m'était rien en péril et pour une raison
assez simple c'est qu'en réalité quand
vous êtes un pays pauvre surendettée
vous êtes endetté à des taux d'intérêt
qui sont très élevés parce qu'il y a une
prime de risque qui est prise par les
acteurs financiers qu'ils soient public
ou privés d'ailleurs et du coup la dette
il la rembourse 3 ou 4 fois donc là
l'annuler ou la restructurer
parce que ils ne peuvent pas payer c'est
déjà la garantie qui a une petite partie
qui sera remboursée alors les
annulations de dette ou les
restructurations de dettes c'est quelque
chose qui est très très courant et en
général ça se fait il y a un club qui
s'était créé pour ça c'est le Club de
Paris qui regroupe jusque jusqu'à ces
dernières années les principaux
créanciers de la planète en gros
Amérique du Nord États-Unis Canada Japon
Australie et puis la plupart des pays
européens sauf que depuis 2008 et c'est
aussi l'un des enjeux de ce sommet
depuis 2008 on a vu les Chinois qui
finançaient massivement la dette
américaine un achetant des bons du
Trésor américain suite à la crise
financière de 2008 progressivement
diversifier leur placement financiers et
investir prêter de plus en plus au pays
du Sud si vous regardez ces dernières
années ces dernières années le montant
des créances détenus par les Chinois et
plus élevé que l'ensemble des créances
du Club de Paris donc l'ensemble des
créances des pré-accordés par les pays
les pays et les pays les plus développés
donc ça c'est une vraie difficultés
parce que la Chine ne renégocie pas ses
lettres
ce qui donne ce qui donne un moyen de
pression à la Chine et puis surtout ce
qui présente un certain intérêt on l'a
vu avec le Sri Lanka quand il s'est
retrouvé en défaut de paiement qui a
fait la Chine oh ben écoutez j'ai
investi dans votre port je l'ai
modernisé finalement il m'appartient
maintenant puisque vous ne pouvez plus
rembourser donc on a ces mécanismes qui
se sont mis en place avec une Chine qui
n'a pas cette habitude de renégocier
cette habitude de restructurer mais en
même temps pour parler des rapports de
force la Chine est dans une situation
extrêmement dangereuse aujourd'hui parce
que si ces pays font massivement défaut
les le défaut se portera sur des
créances chinoises et donc mettons en
péril la Chine une Chine qui a pas
besoin de ça en ce moment on en
reparlera mais c'est aussi c'est
intéressant parce que l'enjeu de ce
sommet c'est aussi de d'envoyer un
message au pays du Sud un message des
Européens et des Occidentaux en général
je vous propose une première réaction
celle des stères Duflot
franco-américaine économistes prix Nobel
d'économie 2019 sur ce sommet l'ensemble
de l'aide par exemple extérieur de la
France et de 17 millions de de 17
milliards de dollars par an
les États-Unis 50
les coûts que nous imposons par nos
choix de consommation en pays pauvres en
termes de vie humaine c'est de l'ordre
de entre 300 et 500 milliards donc on
n'est pas du tout dans notre efforts de
soleil de solidarité aujourd'hui sont
pas du tout dans la
bonne échelle et en plus on en parle un
petit peu comme quelque chose comme de
la charité ou un effort que nous
consentons vis-à-vis de ces pays pauvres
alors qu'en fait c'est vraiment une
responsabilité c'est vraiment payer pour
nous pour nous pour nos choix de vie
aujourd'hui
payer pour nos choix de vie nos choix de
consommation François on ça revient un
peu à ce dont on parlait tout à l'heure
on est dans on est dans quoi on essaie
de l'ordre de
du jugement moral c'est est-ce que ça a
encore sa place dans un monde qui a pas
de gouvernance de gouvernance
globale enfin quoi que toutes les
actions sont la fois morale et politique
la tentative de séparer la morale de la
politique mais pareil assez veine on a
vu le débat entre Emmanuel Macron et et
la première ministre là-dessus vous
faites de la morale il faut faire de la
politique et ont été voilà moi je le
vois pour les fermer les frontières on
croit que fermer les frontières c'est le
politique et couvrir les frontières
c'est moral non les deux gestes dont à
la fois politique et moraux donc il est
c'est la même chose à lutte contre le
changement climatique à une vertu morale
qui me paraît évidente en étant
politique économique etc je trouve que
la dissociation des dimensions est
vraiment artificielle mais quand Esther
Duflot parle de changement de nos de nos
mode de vie on voit aussi que au sein de
la société française c'est une ligne de
fracture oui alors c'est pour ça que
d'ailleurs on suit estime beaucoup les
aspects démographiques le nombre des
hommes parce que c'est beaucoup plus le
mode de vie qui pèse dans cette affaire
que le nombre des hommes si on parce que
souvent on a dit bah ils n'ont qu'à
réduire leur fécondité et donc à réduire
leur population et le problème sera
réglé mais en fait c'est plutôt et c'est
une façon pour nous de nous exonérer du
devoir de changer notre mode de vie
c'est c'est ça le problème alors bien
sûr la question démographique joue mais
elle n'est pas première par rapport à un
mode de vie ultra-consommateur bon c'est
bien que si tout le monde consommait à
l'américaine ou consommer à la manière
des riches du Nigéria que j'ai évoqué
tout à l'heure évidemment ce serait la
fin de la planète je poursuis je
prolonge un peu ce que vous disiez tout
à l'heure cinématelli est-ce qu'il y a
un risque de défaut de paiement parce
que vous disiez ça aurait des
conséquences ça aurait des conséquences
pour la Chine etc est-ce que aujourd'hui
la situation c'est tellement gravé qu'on
approche de ce risque ou pas aujourd'hui
on a des pays effectivement des pays
pauvres qui sont en situation de en
risque de défaut de paiement extrêmement
élevé prenez le je crois qu'il est 54 ou
les 60 pays les plus pauvres de la
planète consacrent aujourd'hui plus de
20% de leur recette fiscales à
rembourser la dette donc vous imaginez
c'est autant d'argent qui n'est pas
investi dans des hôpitaux dans des
écoles mais en plus c'est une somme qui
tente à augmenter parce que les taux
d'intérêts ont augmenté et là aussi de
notre fête on a on a eu des politiques
monétaires qui visaient à lutter contre
l'inflation qui conduisent à une
augmentation des taux d'intérêts et
c'est les pays du Sud qui en payent le
prix cher puisqu'encore une fois eux
payent des taux d'intérêt encore plus
élevés parce qu'il y a une prime de
risque qui est donc très clairement on
est en situation de de risques de défaut
et c'est quelque chose qui inquiétait
énormément les Chinois rappelez-vous au
mois de janvier au Forum de Davos l'un
des vis Premier ministre chinois avaient
expliqué qu'il fallait gérer cette dette
cette risque de défaut dans les pays du
Sud que c'était notre responsabilité etc
etc dans le viseur il avait bien
évidemment c'est les créances que lui
détient et qu'il risque de ne jamais
recouvrer en réalité et avec une
conséquence c'est le l'accroissement de
la de l'écart et l'accroissement de la
pauvreté on va en parler tout de suite
avec tam-trans nuit qui peut nous
rejoindre sur ce plateau avec on va
découvrir j'avoue que je ne savais pas
ce que c'était l'indice de développement
humain c'est passionnant ça permet
d'évaluer effectivement
l'état de la pauvreté de quoi il s'agit
alors voilà on va faire un point de
méthode pour commencer l'indice de
développement humain ou idéal c'est
l'indicateur qui est calculé chaque
année par les relations unies pour
mesurer le développement des pays pour
cela on croise des données on croise le
niveau de vie le PIB par habitant on
croise la santé l'espérance de vie et
l'éducation en prenant la durée de
scolarisation cet indice il est compris
entre 0 et 1 0 c'est pas terrible du
tout et un c'est le niveau de
développement maximum il permet de
classer les pays en différentes
catégories vous avez l'IDH très élevé
par exemple la Suisse ou encore la
France vous avez l'IDH élevé Équateur ou
encore Vietnam l'IDH moyen et Mala
Myanmar ou encore faible Érythrée
Afghanistan voilà pour la méthode et cet
indice de développement humain il a
connu selon l'ONU à un repli un recul
majeur récemment et oui l'idéal c'était
en constante augmentation depuis une
trentaine d'années et il a été stoppé
net par la pandémie de covid c'est ce
que l'on voit sur cette courbe qui va
s'afficher qui est issue du rapport du
programme des Nations Unies pour le
développement qui a été publiée en
septembre dernier on voit vous voyez
elle se casse en 2020 on est même
retombé au niveau de 2016 ce qui veut
dire que la pandémie a fait perdre au
monde 4-5 ans de développement et la
tendance aller globale elle est
généralisée ce qui a fait dire au patron
du pneu de kimchtiner cela veut dire que
nous mourrons plutôt que nous sommes
moins éduqués et que nos revenus
baissent quels sont les pays qui ont le
plus souffert oui parce que si on y
regarde de plus près les pays développés
s'en sont beaucoup mieux tirés que les
pays en développement alors parmi ceux
qui ont le plus souffert vous avez
l'Amérique latine les Caraïbes l'Afrique
subsaharienne l'Asie du Sud parce que en
réalité si 90% du monde a vu son IDH BC
en 2020 l'année suivante vous n'en avez
plus que 40% dont l'indice continue à
baisser l'année suivante donc vous en
avez qui ont creusé la courbe et
d'autres qui ont réussi à remonter la
tête et on va le regarder encore sur un
autre graphique on a des données vous
des données en vert clair c'est l'année
2020 et voyez là tout le monde est
touché à peu près 90% des pays quel que
soit leur IDH ont vu leur développement
BC et ensuite et bien vous voyez en vert
foncé que vous avez seulement 30 % des
pays développés qui sont encore affectés
contre 60% des pays moins développés qui
voient encore leurs idées HBC ce qui
veut dire que la crise a agrafé les
inégalités de développement il n'y a pas
que la pandémie que le covid qui
explique cette crise non le Programme
des Nations Unies pour le Développement
parle d'une crise mondiale multiforme
crise financière crise climatique qui se
poursuit pandémie de covid-19 et crise
alimentaire qui s'annonce le tableau est
donc très très sombre mais tout n'est
pas perdu pour corriger le tir et faire
remonter notre indice de développement
les Nations Unies proposent trois pistes
d'une part les investissements dans les
énergies renouvelables pour contrer les
futurs pandémies propose également
l'assurance la protection sociale pour
mieux absorber les chocs et enfin
l'innovation pour mieux réagir aux
prochaines crises et à cela il faut
aussi ajouter le fait d'accentuer l'aide
au développement pour les pays les plus
vinables au cœur de ce sommet qui se
tient à Paris merci tam-tam pour toutes
ces informations François iron a un mot
sur la pandémie de covid pourquoi ça a
cet effet sur sur l'indice de
développement humain il y a eu des alors
il y a la mortalité c'est ça s'explique
aussi par ça
n'est pas ça n'est pas un croisement
pourrait-on précis c'est un score
composite il y a des années d'éducation
il y a des années d'expérience de vie il
y a la richesse par habitant et ce qui a
le plus se reculer dans cet indice
composite c'est l'espérance de vie dans
tous les pays du Sud on a on a perdu à
peu près 10 ans de progrès d'espérance
de vie à cause de de du covid et alors
il peut y avoir aussi une réduction du
niveau de vie mais c'est surtout le
recul de la de l'espérance de vie qui a
qui explique ses baisses
est-ce que François Heron on peut
chiffrer
que dans nos pays c'est quoi c'est c'est
une toute petite partie pourcentage de
la population dans les pays les plus
pauvres c'est quoi le ratio est-ce que
est-ce que on a on peut aller jusque là
le ratio c'est à dire clair la
différence entre entre un pays riche
comme la France et et un pays africain
parmi les plus pauvres en mortalité
absolument considérable sans différence
considérable entre le Niger ou
l'Afghanistan qui sont en bas du
classement et la Norvège la Suisse etc
il y a des écarts absolument
considérables et alors il y a des pays
qui ont qui ont fait reculer leur
pauvreté comme la Chine par exemple sur
des décennies c'est très clair mais
globalement toute la bande sahélienne
est encore extrêmement touchée je vais
poser Guillaume campagne question
volontairement provocatrice est-ce que
le est-ce que c'est pas une bonne
nouvelle pour la planète que l'indice de
développement humain soit soit en train
de de s'affaisser je pense que vous
connaissez ma réponse je pense que c'est
une réponse qui est humaine c'est de
dire non évidemment
c'est effectivement il y a on estime
qu'à un recul de enfin une disons que la
lutte contre la pauvreté a perdu 10 ans
dans la bataille entre guillemets depuis
la pandémie de covid mais aussi
l'invasion
ukrainienne par la Russie qui a aussi
provoqué des chocs sur le prix des
denrées alimentaires
alimentaires en plus par de la
spéculation et différentes dynamiques
oui c'est c'est extrêmement
problématique c'est extrêmement
préoccupant et d'autant plus que en
effet le changement climatique n'est pas
vécu de la même manière dans tous les
pays on a parlé des ravages dans les
pays les plus vulnérables je vous
parlais tout à l'heure des 10 pays les
plus vulnérables au changement
climatique au monde ils sont
responsables historiquement de 0,4% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
pourtant ils sont en première ligne
d'inondation de sécheresse qui provoque
effectivement des crises alimentaires
majeures dans ces pays-là dans ces 10
pays là la fin a doublé depuis 2016 donc
on voit bien les corrélations et
évidemment je parle même pas les impacts
sur la santé et donc parce que je
reprends ma question derrière ça il y
avait la question de la croissance ou de
la décroissance c'est-à-dire qu'on peut
laisser ces pays croître leur impact
climatique sera faible c'est
ça il y a une étude d'Auxonne qui a été
faite il y a quelques années qui
montrait il y a pas très longtemps qui
montrait que 1 % les 1 % des individus
les plus riches de la planète par leur
mode de consommation justement et mettre
deux fois plus que la moitié la plus
faible de la population mondiale
c'est-à-dire que la moitié la plus la
plus pauvre la moitié la plus pauvre de
la population mondiale c'est environ 7%
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
10% les plus riches c'est la moitié des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
mondial on voit bien les les ordres de
grandeur qui sont colossaux alors il y a
une promesse qui avait été faite par les
par les pays les plus riches il y a une
quinzaine d'années c'était de donner 100
milliards par an justement pour contrer
ce cet impact du réchauffement
climatique je vous propose avant de vous
entendre les uns les autres là-dessus
d'écouter le président de la Banque
africaine de développement à Kimi à
dessiner
à elle seule l'Afrique perd 7 à 15
milliards de dollars par an à cause du
changement climatique et ce chiffre
passera près de 50 milliards de dollars
par an d'ici 2040 le monde doit donc
respecter son engagement les pays
développés à hauteur de 100 milliards de
dollars je veux dire que c'est une très
petite somme d'argent comparée à
l'ampleur du problème mais en de la
respectant pas il y a une crise de
confiance dans les pays en voie de
développement alors on va remonter
d'abord à l'origine cinématis donc 2009
pourquoi il y a ce pourquoi il y a cette
cette promesse on va voir après si elle
est tenue c'est lors d'une coque vous ne
corrigez seulement 30 mais c'est lors de
la Coop de Copenhague en fait et il y a
toujours eu au sein des cops ce débat et
entre les pays du Sud et les pays les
plus développés les pays du Sud
réclamant une solidarité un juste retour
en fait sur le fait qu'on est
responsable nous pays les plus
développés des émissions de CO2 et qui
serait très juste qu'on les aide qu'on
les accompagne par des transferts
financiers mais aussi par des transferts
de technologie à se protéger que ce
changement climatique donc les pays
parviennent à s'entendre sur ce sur ce
fond je crois que c'était le fond vert
le nom du fond à la base
et
on s'engage à
accumuler ces 100 milliards et à payer
ses 100 milliards à partir de 2020 or en
réalité en 2020 je crois qu'on était à
peine à 60 milliards ou il en manquait
beaucoup et le problème c'est que on
s'aperçoit que le changement climatique
s'accélère donc les 100 milliards ne
seront pas suffisants et surtout on se
demande aujourd'hui comment on va te
rattraper le retard prix sur le non
versement de ce fond ce qui est aussi
intéressant sur ce cette question là et
c'est aussi l'un des enjeux de cette de
ce sommet aujourd'hui c'est que regarder
hier ou avant-hier il y avait une
conférence à Londres pour aider
l'Ukraine et reconstruire l'Ukraine avec
vous avez vu les montants avec le
secteur privé on est dans des ordres de
grandeur de 400 milliards voire plus
donc là aussi il y a un signal à envoyer
au pays du Sud au fond on est prêt à
payer 400 milliards pour reconstruire
l'Ukraine et on a du mal accumuler 100
milliards pour aider les pays du Sud à
lutter contre le changement climatique
changement climatique qui nous touche
nous aussi donc c'est vrai que ben il y
a deux poids de mesure qui est très très
questionnant pour ces pays-là est-ce
qu'il y a pas un changement aussi parce
que ces pays dit du Sud global ont cessé
de s'aligner sur le modèle occidental et
donc il est plus difficile il y a une
fracture qui s'est créée puisque quand
on dénonce un modèle
occidental et qui cherche à nous dominer
et qu'on rejette ce modèle c'est
difficile après pour les occidentaux de
donner plus facilement non il n'y a pas
quelque chose aussi d'ordre peut-être
politique et moral on en parle
géopolitique la confrontation si le mot
est peut-être un peu fort mais il y a
pas d'autres mots qui qui me viennent en
tête à l'instant la confrontation entre
le sud et les pays les plus développés
ou en tout cas l'Occident dominant elle
date elle date de beaucoup plus
longtemps on a eu parlé des non-alignés
mais même au début du 20e siècle il y
avait déjà cette idée que c'était pas
normal que l'Occident
sa loi comme elle l'imposait ça c'est
certain accepter le modèle et on voulait
s'aligner comme ça ce modèle
démocratique on cherchait à jouer à
attendre peut-être ce qui change
aujourd'hui je suis pas sûr que les pays
du Sud tendaient vers le modèle
démocratique c'est plutôt c'est plutôt
une contrainte ou en tout cas une
pression que l'on faisait sur eux mais
ce qui est intéressant aujourd'hui il y
a un certain opportunisme des
Occidentaux à organiser ce type de
conférence c'est évident tant mieux si
ça profite au pays du Sud d'ailleurs
l'opportunisme il vient du fait
qu'aujourd'hui il y a des grandes
puissances aussi au sud et des grandes
puissances qui sont en train de
récupérer toutes ces velléités de peser
des pays du Sud c'est bien évidemment la
Chine avec beaucoup d'efficacité on
parlait tout à l'heure des créances que
détient la Chine sur le sur ces pays
mais il y a aussi la Russie il y a aussi
la Russie et donc bien évidemment il y a
un enjeu énorme de la part des
occidentaux que de d'expliquer que nous
aussi on peut changer nous aussi on peut
aller des CPI qu'il n'y a pas que la
Chine dans la dans la lutte je reviens à
la promesse des 100 milliards Guillaume
Compain alors je crois qu'Emmanuel
Macron se félicitait de dire ça y est on
va enfin l'atteindre cette année alors
un est-ce que les 100 milliards sont
effectivement
versées et puis ensuite est-ce que ça
suffit parce que je crois qu'on est très
très loin du compte d'après vos calculs
il y a 3 semaines sur la réalité des
financements climats qu'on a procédé une
analyse rendre la qualité de ses
financements comment ils étaient fléchés
ou ils étaient fléchés et en fait on se
rend compte que l'écart entre la les
annonces faites donc là pour 2020 pour
répondre à la question on était sur
quelque chose de l'ordre de 83 milliards
déclarés par les pays riches en termes
de financement climat mais sur ces 83
milliards ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est
qu'il y a énormément de prêts souvent
avec des taux ce qu'on appelle
concessionnelle donc c'est à dire un peu
moins cher que les taux de marchés
classiques mais parfois aussi à des taux
tout ce qu'il y a de plus classique et
en réalité des pays c'est exactement ça
c'est à dire que évidemment que dans
certains cas des prêts peuvent être
utiles mais quand la majorité de ces
financements climats sont fournissent
sous forme de prêts qui effectivement
contribue à l'endettement de ces pays on
se demande où est la solidarité et la
responsabilité de ses financements
climats faut savoir enfin typiquement du
coup sur ce montant de 24 milliards que
nous on évalue c'est-à-dire on estime
que la réalité de ces financement climat
c'est 24 milliards dont 11 milliards
pour l'adaptation au changement
climatique 11 milliards c'est un quart
de ce que les Américains dépensent pour
leur chien et chats chaque année en
nourriture donc c'est bon c'est
évidemment une comparaison qui cherche à
interpeller mais je pense qu'elle est
quand même assez parlante et donc je
repose la question sur le montant parce
que là on est en train de se dire est-ce
que les 100 milliards sont vraiment
versés sous forme de prêt pas sous forme
de prêt etc mais il faudrait combien
d'argent alors bien plus et justement
c'est aussi un des une des grandes
grandes limites de Copenhague en 2009
c'est qu'on est tombé sur un chiffre
rond 100 milliards qui faisait bien mais
qui n'étaient basé sur aucune analyse
concrète des besoins un chiffre
politique quoi
quand on va creuser la nature des
besoins typiquement il y a plusieurs
études qui sont sortis récemment le GIEC
dans son dernier rapport a fait une
évaluation estimé qu'en moyenne on est
sur de l'ordre de 2300 ouais 2200-2300
milliards de dollars par an en besoin
pour les pays du Sud ne serait-ce que
pour atténuer leurs émissions
c'est-à-dire transitionner vers des
systèmes énergétiques
0 carbone et résilient en plus de ça il
faut ajouter environ 400 milliards c'est
une évaluation des pertes dommages c'est
à dire en gros toutes les conséquences
irréversibles du changement climatique
dans les pays du Sud d'ailleurs on parle
de pays du Sud mais en fait c'est pour
dire les pays majoritaires parce que
c'est l'essentiel de la population
mondiale
400 milliards par an aussi et on est à
peu près sur des ordres de grandeur
similaires d'après donc c'est le
Programme des Nations Unies pour
l'Environnement qui évalue dans un
rapport annuel 400 milliards environ de
besoins annuels pour s'adapter donc pour
pour transformer notre agriculture pour
avoir des des chaleurs moins écrasantes
parce qu'on va refore rester ce genre de
d'initiative là je pense qu'il y a eu
récemment un éditorial je crois du
sous-directeur de la Banque mondiale
expliquant que les subventions au
combustibles fossiles sont actuellement
plus importantes que l'ensemble des
aides pour lutter contre le climat donc
c'est quand même navrant est-ce que si
je si on est cynique l'un des objets de
ce objectif de ce sommet c'est pas aussi
de réduire les les flux migratoires les
réfugiés climatiques alors dans
l'ensemble des Colocs et des qui qui
accompagnent enfin qui composent le le
toutes les réunions qui ont lieu en ce
moment la migration n'apparaît pas
c'est un problème quand même assez
différent parce que la relation entre le
changement climatique et la migration
elle est assez compliquée il y a d'abord
c'est compliqué de faire des études il
faut regarder des images de satellites
sur l'état des sols la pluviosité des
choses comme ça au moins pendant 20 ans
et médecin en corrélation avec la des
populations très difficiles établir
parce que tous les pays n'ont pas des
recensements ou de bonne enquête enfin
il y a quelques études qui ont réussi à
faire ça et le résultat est parfois
paradoxal lorsqu’un pays a une
sécheresse qui s'accentue et bien ça
peut diminuer les ressources des gens et
diminuer leur probabilités de migrer
etc pas seulement le voyage afin de et
donc du coup la migration c'est une
adaptation une adaptation notamment au
changement climatique mais qui n'est pas
la portée de tout le monde c'est c'est
sélectif et donc il peut y avoir des
effets contraires la sécheresse peut
limiter la capacité à migrer au lieu de
de l'augmenter voilà un peu le et si
vous voulez ce qui les études qui ont
été faites bon il y en a beaucoup c'est
un grand sujet maintenant bien sûr
compris dans l'institut convergence
migration que je dirige au moins une
dizaine de personnes qui travaillent sur
le sujet
la relation entre le changement de la
dégradation du climat et la migration
elle est indirecte ça intensifie l'exode
rural l'exode rural accroît organisation
l'urbanisation peut par exemple la
croître la violence c'est un exemple la
violence à Croix la propension à émigré
à l'extérieur mais ce que les bases de
données qui existent actuellement sur le
lien entre climat immigration c'est
essentiellement des bases sur les
déplacés internes c'est à dire les
personnes déplacées à l'intérieur de
leur pays il n'y a pas actuellement de
base de données fiables démontrant ou
permettant de mesurer les miels les
déplacements externes qui seraient
provoqués par le changement et donc ça
c'est vrai pour aujourd'hui est-ce que
vous faites aussi des projections voilà
à 10 15 ou 20 ans pour dire que si le
les conséquences du réchauffement
climatique sont celles que
malheureusement on imagine il y aura
plus de réfugiés il y a des projections
classiques consistant évidemment
anticipées par exemple la montée des
eaux qui est un phénomène qu'on peut
quantifier à ces aimants et qui est plus
rapide que ce qu'on avait envisagé il y
a une quinzaine d'années et on sait
quelle est la part de la population
mondiale qui vit à moins d'un kilomètre
des côtes donc là oui on peut se dire
qu'il y a un temps étant de de centaines
de millions de d'habitants et qui
aimeraient être touchés par le la montée
des eaux sans que cela provoque
nécessairement une immigration
internationale ce qui est un peu
compliqué dans cette affaire c'est que
déjà autrefois par exemple quand il y
avait
toutes les populations rurales en
surnombre dans les montagnes françaises
elles étaient soumises à une volatilité
du climat des aléas climatiques énormes
toutes les chroniques en parlent et pour
lisser ça à titre d'assurance et bien
les familles envoyer quelqu'un
travailler dans les villes dans le Nord
etc et le la première industrialisation
française c'est beaucoup fait avec du
travail partiel l'agriculteur donc c'est
très difficile de faire une séparation
entre la migration économique classique
des sahéliens par exemple aujourd'hui et
la migration économique parce que une
bonne partie des migrations économiques
actuelles c'est déjà une espèce
d'assurance contre les variations du
climat qui ne date pas d'aujourd'hui
même si évidemment le phénomène
s'aggrave on va parler faire un peu de
politique Laetitia on va s'intéresser
aux enjeux autour de d'Emmanuel Macron
qui est qui est pas le seul il était
avec la première ministre de la Barbade
et les deux sont à l'initiative de ce
sommet c'est évidemment une opportunité
politique pour le président français
qu'est-ce qu'on peut en dire qu'est-ce
qui joue lui personnellement dans ce
mail après vous il joue
je crois qu'il joue le jeu qu'il a
commencé en 2017 quand on regarde
vraiment le premier quinquennat et le
second Emmanuel Macron organise des
sommets internationaux sur tous les
sujets d'accord et il perpétue
uniquement la tradition golienne parce
que je peux vous dire Thomas c'est très
documenté ça tous ces sommets quand on
organise et qu'on a un chef d'État
français ça n'a quasiment aucun impact
sur la notoriété ou le gain d'image vous
pouvez y aller en France à tous les
institutions d'âge ont déjà fait des
études et ça n'a aucun impact donc
Emmanuel Macron finalement perpétude je
le disais la tradition gaulienne ce rôle
de grand médiateur mondial et jouer par
la France depuis le général de Gaulle en
passant par Jacques Chirac qui lui avait
multiplié les sommets franco-fricains et
c'est vrai que quel que soit le contexte
la France a organisé des sommets
accueilli les chefs d'État du monde
entier par exemple au début des années
60 c'était le début de la guerre froide
et le général de Gaulle avait tenu à
venir les Occidentaux et le russe
cruchoff avec plus ou moins de
soubresauts ça je vous invite à regarder
vos archives mais c'est vrai que ça n'a
rien donc il y a une tradition française
on peut dire une tradition de
non-alignement aussi ça c'est une
dimension importante exactement parce
que les liens avec les États-Unis sont
maintenus Emmanuel Macron bien sûr elles
sont quasiment intouchables même mais
c'est vrai que le président en français
a toujours voulu conserver un contact
avec Vladimir Poutine ça c'est très
clair il l'a fait savoir et le
multipolarisme du monde aujourd'hui de
lui donne raison parce que on en a parlé
un peu tout à l'heure mais quand même la
guerre en Ukraine a creusé à augmenter
cette fracture entre les Occidentaux et
les pays extièrement dit aujourd'hui du
Sud global et c'est vrai que quand même
il y a peut-être une incompréhension
parce que ces pays n'ont jamais condamné
l'invasion russe et aussi continue de
fustiger la domination du
occidental donc il n'y a pas chez
Emmanuel Macron une soudaine comme ça
course à la postérité à la notoriété
pour ça postérité non non les forums de
Paris regardez les forums de Paris pour
la paix alors il y en a eu vraiment de
beaucoup beaucoup de 2017 et aussi le
One Ocean semi on en a parlé tout à
l'heure c'était Brest février 2022
prochains chantiers d'Emmanuel Macron à
un sommet de la paix en Ukraine ça fait
partie des projets ça aussi on l'a pris
le 15 avril dernier à l'occasion d'un
échange téléphonique vous savez qu'à
chaque fois ils sont rendus public donc
on le sait avec le président
Zelinski et Zelinski que c'était lui
qu'il avait donné cette idée au G7 il
est arrivé avec cette idée elle lui
avait été retoquée parce que c'était pas
possible il voulait un sommet sur la
paix mondiale Emmanuel Macron lui aussi
veut organiser ce sommet mais pour
l'instant ce projet est au point mort
alors si Mathis c'est un peu le
sous-titre de ce de ce sommet ce pour un
nouveau pack financier mondial
que vous détournez pas des occidentaux
on pourrait on pourrait dire ça c'est
l'enjeu ou bien au-delà d'Emmanuel
Macron des Européens des Occidentaux en
général je rajouterais même vous avez
besoin de nous parce qu'en fait c'est ça
qu'on leur explique on est la question
qui est posée aussi dans ce sommet c'est
la question de la réforme des grandes
organisations économiques
internationales
issues de Breton Woods en 1944 largement
décidé par les Britanniques et les
Américains d'abord accompagnés des
Britanniques donc les alliés et qui
aujourd'hui du fait de l'essor de la de
la Chine dans les relations commerciales
mais aussi financières à ces pays du Sud
a quand même beaucoup moins d'emprises
et d'impact et donc l'idée c'est de dire
mais revenez vers nous nous on peut vous
offrir des solutions alternatives alors
la question est posée la réforme est
proposée les États-Unis étaient pas très
friands de ce de cette réforme il y a
quelques années je suis pas sûr qu'ils
aient changé de position depuis
y a nos confrères du magazine challenge
je sais pas si vous avez vu ça et qui
nous disent qui Emmanuel Macron envisage
un ISF mondial il pourrait lancer l'idée
à l'occasion du prochain G20 au mois de
septembre ça c'est drôle votre réaction
je la trouve spontanée ça vous fait rire
ça est-ce que ça pourrait ressembler à
cette impôt minimum sur les
multinationales qui a quand même été
décidé est-ce que voilà ce qui me
faisait sourire c'est qu'on laisse
dire que si je le supprime en France on
perd en attractivité et donc il faut que
ce soit une décision mondiale pour que
ça ne ça ne
pleure pas pour un pays alors plusieurs
éléments déjà la taxation sur les
grandes multinationales les 15 % dont
vous parliez et qui rentre en vigueur au
1er janvier 2024 si je me souviens bien
ça c'est quelque chose qui paraît assez
logique l'idée c'est de corriger une
anomalie de la mondialisation qui permet
à de grandes entreprises parce qu'elles
sont localisées partout sur la planète
de ne quasiment pas payer l'impôt et le
15% on est quand même très très loin du
taux de 25% qui avait été proposé au
départ et qui est à peu près le taux
moyen d'imposition des entreprises dans
les pays les plus développés donc ça
c'est un premier élément c'est un
élément qui est intéressant et je crois
que c'est intéressant ces questions de
la fiscalité parce qu'elles reviennent
de plus en plus souvent depuis que les
pays les plus développés se sont aperçus
avec la pandémie de covid etc qu'ils
avaient besoin d'argent
euh on mélange parfois un peu tout
c'est-à-dire quand on ouvre ce débat en
France ah mais regardez tous les impôts
qu'on paye il y a énormément
d'entreprises et d'individus aujourd'hui
qui ne payent pas l'impôt qu'il aurait
payé donc avant de créer de nouveaux
impôts peut-être et le taux de 15 % et
le projet de 15 % va dans ce sens-là
peut-être commençons à faire payer à
tout le monde le même niveau d'impôts et
déjà on aura une de meilleur contrôle ça
veut dire des accords internationaux
comme cet accord sur la taxation
mondiale je vous rappelle que la
proposition avait été faite par l'OCDE
en 2008 on est arrivé à un accord en
2022 donc ça a pris quand même un
certain temps et il a fallu que les pays
du Nord eux aussi sont acculés face au
poids de leurs dettes se disent et là il
faut peut-être trouver de l'argent
quelque part cette idée d'un ISSF
mondial ça rejoint ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure donc on parle des plus
grandes fortunes et qui sont les plus
gros pollueurs en fait plus on est riche
plus on pollue exactement il y a un
rapport qui est sorti l'année dernière
donc ça m'international qui a évalué à
peu près la en gros l'impact de la du
portefeuille financier de 125
milliardaires à travers le monde à
l'empreinte carbone de tous les Français
enfin du territoire français d'accord
parce que ce qu'on estime c'est que par
leur prise de participation et leur
possession souvent de l'entièreté de ces
entreprises en fait ils ont des pouvoirs
de décision énorme sur la façon dont ces
entreprises vont évoluer vont
transitionner et donc en refusant
d'injecter massivement de l'argent dans
la transition en refusant de peser sur
sur l'évolution de ces entreprises on
peut estimer que c'est tout à fait
légitime d'imputer ses émissions de gaz
à effet de serre à ces milliardaires je
le disais tout à l'heure les émissions
des plus riches en termes de
consommation donc de mode de vie elles
sont disproportionnées par rapport à la
population générale et la population
mondiale encore davantage donc c'est non
seulement légitime à notre sens mais
c'est même une proposition qu'on fait
donc on est on est ravi de savoir que le
Président de la République souhaite
établir une imposition des plus riches
c'est nos confrères de challenges qui
disent que l'idée est dans les dans les
cartons
un peu temporisé mais voilà mais nous on
pense qu'il faut pas temporiser on pense
même que effectivement des fois les des
conventions internationales peuvent
prendre du temps ça va être compliqué
mais je pense que le genre vaut la
chandelle de manière la plus inclusive
possible
un mot des chiffres et plus largement on
pense que oui on pourrait rétablir dès
maintenant un ISF en France ça serait
tout à fait pertinent merci à tous on
sera terminé là-dessus je rappelle
François Hollande le titre de votre
livre immigration le grand déni livre
publié aux éditions du Seuil voilà c'est
la fin de ce numéro de sens public merci
à toutes et à tous je vous dis à lundi
vous pouvez retrouver tous les
programmes de la chaîne sur la
plateforme Public Sénat point FR et puis
notez que deux mains dans la matinale de
Public Sénat Oriane Poncini reçoit
George Sérignac le grand maître du Grand
Orient de France belle soirée à toutes
et à tous